-President Trump
is reportedly preparing
for special counsel
Robert Mueller
to issue his final report
as early as next week.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
After Trump declared
a national emergency
to bypass Congress
and build his border wall,
16 states filed legal challenges
almost immediately.
In comments to reporters
this week,
Trump insisted
he had the absolute right
to unilaterally build his wall
and said it was a matter
of national security.
-We have absolute right
to do that.
I have an absolute right
to call national security.
We need strong borders.
It's an open and closed case.
I was put here for security,
whether it's Space Force,
which we're doing today,
or whether it's borders.
-Space Force and borders.
It's pretty telling
that despite the effects
of climate change, gun violence,
and inadequate healthcare,
Trump thinks
the biggest threats to America
are asylum seekers and Klingons.
I mean, hell,
why not combine the two
and deploy the Space Force
to the border?
The national...
[ Cheers and applause ]
The national-emergency
declaration is just the latest
example of Trump's disregard
for the rule of law.
Republicans have elected a guy
who tramples over
the Constitution
after spending years
lecturing the rest of us
about the Constitution.
And even though
he clearly didn't mean it,
Trump repeatedly promised
during the campaign
that he would restore
the rule of law.
-We have to restore
the rule of law
on our border,
in our government.
No matter where it is,
it has to be restored.
In my administration,
I'm going to enforce all laws
concerning the protection
of classified information.
[ Cheers and applause ]
No one will be above the law.
This election will determine
whether we remain a free country
in the truest sense of the word
or we become a corrupt
banana republic
controlled by large "derners"
and foreign governments.
-I'm sorry. Real quick.
Can we hear that word again?
-Controlled by large derners.
-Did you mean to say "donors"?
Why do you sound like Madea?
That's like saying Congress
is going to pass a "ler"
or reminding everyone
to get out and "vert."
But you heard Trump
very clearly there.
The government would not be
controlled by large derners
or, more importantly,
foreign governments.
The President
of the United States
will put Americans
above everyone else, period.
-In his latest interviews,
as well as in his new book,
the former FBI acting director
Andrew McCabe
recounts a time President Trump
refused to believe information
from top U.S. intelligence
officials,
preferred instead to take the
word of Russia's Vladimir Putin.
-The President said he did not
believe that the North Koreans
had the capability to hit us
here with ballistic missiles
in the United States.
And he did not believe that
because President Putin
had told him they did not.
Intelligence officials
in the briefing responded
that that was not consistent
with any of the intelligence
our government possesses.
To which the President replied,
"I don't care. I believe Putin."
-He told American
intelligence officials
he believed Putin over them.
Say what you will about Trump,
he might be a criminal,
but at least he's super-obvious
about it.
It's like if someone asked
Barry Bonds
if he wanted to take
batting practice,
and he said, "Not right now.
I have to go take my steroids."
Why on Earth
would you believe Putin
over your own
intelligence officials,
unless you had some sort of
corrupt relationship with him?
He's not exactly
the most trustworthy guy.
I mean, look at him.
That's the same way
Dexter used to smile at people
when they came to
strapped to a table.
You trusted a guy
with resting Dexter face.
In interviews this month,
McCabe has detailed the extent
to which Trump tried to
interfere in the various
investigations
of him and his closest aides.
For example,
after Trump fired James Comey
and McCabe took over
as acting FBI director,
Trump tried to claim
that Comey was widely
disliked within the FBI.
And he even tried to get McCabe
to say he also hated Comey,
which was not true.
-The President
immediately went off
on almost a gleeful description
of what had happened
with the firing of Jim Comey.
And then he went on to state
that people in the FBI
were thrilled about this,
that people
really disliked Jim Comey,
and that they were very happy
about this
and that it was a great thing.
What I was hearing from
the President was not reality.
It was the version of the events
that I quickly realized
he wished me to adopt.
And he said, "I heard
that you were one of the people
that did not support Jim Comey.
You didn't agree with him
and the decisions that he made
in the Clinton case.
Is that true?"
And I said,
"No, sir, that's not true."
-Trump thinks
he can Jedi mind-trick you
into believing something.
He's like one of those
old-timey villains
with black-and-white swirls
for eyes.
"You hated James Comey."
"No, I liked him."
"No, you hated him."
"What's wrong with your eyes?"
"Oh, they're transplants.
From a derner."
[ Laughter ]
McCabe was worried...
[ Applause ]
McCabe was worried
that the President
was trying to interfere
in the Russia investigation,
which was obviously true.
In fact, Trump started
to install loyalists
who he knew he could control,
like his recently departed
acting attorney general,
Matt Whitaker.
Whitaker refused
to recuse himself
from the Russia investigation,
and a few weeks ago,
he even insisted the
investigation was winding down,
although he seemed
super nervous about it.
-Before you came
into your current role,
you were publicly very critical
of the special counsel
investigation.
Now since you have received
your briefings,
is there anything
that you've seen or read
that gives you concern about
special counsel Robert Mueller
or his investigation?
-You know, I've been fully
briefed on the investigation.
And, you know, I look forward
to Director Mueller
delivering the final report,
but right now, you know,
the investigation is,
I think,
close to being completed,
and I hope that we can get
the report from Director Mueller
as soon as we -- as possible.
-Look at how sweaty he is.
He looks like a glass of
iced tea on a hot summer day.
Somebody put that guy
on a coaster.
Trump installed Whitaker to
get the various investigations
of him and his associates
under control,
like Michael Cohen,
who was being investigated
by the U.S. Attorney for the
Southern district of New York.
And this week,
"The New York Times" reported
that Trump tried to get Whitaker
to put an ally of his
in charge of
the Cohen investigation.
-"The Times" reports that while
Manhattan's federal prosecutors
were gathering evidence
on Trump's involvement
in hush-money payments
during the 2016 election,
Trump called former acting
attorney general
Matthew Whitaker.
"Trump asked
whether Geoffrey S. Berman,
the United States Attorney
for the Southern district
of New York, and a Trump ally,
could be put in charge
of the widening investigation,
according to several
American officials
with direct knowledge
of the call."
-So Trump tried to get Whitaker
to interfere in the
investigation of Michael Cohen.
Can you imagine
how much Whitaker was sweating
during that phone call?
Probably looked like
he just climbed out of a pool.
Now, there's been
speculation for months
that special counsel
Robert Mueller's investigation
is wrapping up or winding down,
and it's never been true,
but now this week,
there's new reporting
that Justice Department
officials are expecting
Mueller's final report
as soon as next week.
And if that's the case,
it could come when Trump
is out of the country.
-We have the clearest
indication yet
that special counsel
Robert Mueller
is nearly done with his
almost two-year investigation
and that the end game here
is near.
Sources say the Justice
Department is preparing
to announce
as early as next week
that Attorney General Bill Barr
has received Mueller's
confidential report.
And soon after
that announcement,
Barr will review the findings
and then submit his own summary
to Congress.
-If it were released next week,
it would happen
as the President
was in Hanoi, Vietnam,
meeting for the second time with
North Korean leader Kim Jong-un.
-So Trump might be
out of the country in Hanoi
when Mueller issues his report.
If that happens,
there's a good chance
Trump just won't come back.
"Kim, you got to smuggle me
back to North Korea.
Hide me in your coat."
How much more evidence
do we need
that Trump was trying
to obstruct justice?
He told Comey to shut down his
investigation of Michael Flynn.
When Comey refused,
he fired him.
He bragged to the Russians
he fired Comey
because of the
Russia investigation,
and he tried to interfere in the
investigation of Michael Cohen.
The evidence is clear.
When this is all over, Trump
is either gonna go to jail
or he's gonna have to resign
and flee and join the...
-Space Force.
-This has been "A Closer Look."